2009 c'était le temps de l'espoir du
changement
pendant plus de moi une grande partie de
la population est mobilisée autour de la
vie chère dix ans plus tard une poignée
de syndicats martiniquais ne renie rien
et veut croire que tout est encore
possible
nous allons démontrer car la faveur des
gilets jaunes et que nous aussi nous
avons la capacité également toujours
comme un ans a mobilisé travail et nos
travailleurs
l'intersyndicale réfute toute démarche
purement mémorielle il se veut dans
l'action mais les modalités les
approches sont différentes
la cgtm par exemple s'inscrit d'emblée
dans le rapport de force avec un préavis
de grève de 24 heures reconductible haut
niveau les municipaux nous disent
apolitiques et pas signé mais c'est à
quoi nous nous assignons peut affecter
exactement quand la guadeloupe jeudi à
dix ans appartient pas respecter donc
nous obliger à lui déposé un préavis de
grève et nous dépose un préavis de golf
à notre commune martinique et il nous
implanter puisque nous avons noté un
ordre de 30 communes à la cdmt le son de
cloche est pour l'instant plus nuancé
jordi jours et pas s'agit simplement de
commémorer de fait débat et bossa il
s'agit de bien des jo dia les problèmes
qui lie jodias qui a bravé il s'agit de
réaliser en plateforme
et puis il s'agit de réfléchir encore en
laye les formes de lutte
bien sûr une défendre le traditionnel
la manifestation la grève tout ça pas
des modèles mais peut-être que l'idée
innovation vous fait pour nous plus
efficace en tout cas nous le disent que
tous ensemble et réfléchissent ensemble
et puis les moments qui a semblé le sec
je veux qu'ils se soient les militants
que ce soit la population aujourd'hui ce
sont des intérêts corporatistes ou les
traditionnels combats syndicaux comme
les revalorisations salariales qui sont
tenir le haut de la fiche bien loin de
la lutte contre la vie chère qui avaient
su fédérer la mobilisation en 2009 le 5
février 2019 sera donc surtout
l'occasion de sonner encore une fois la
larme sociale qui retentit depuis 10 ans
déjà et de compter ceux qui répondent à
l'appel